the attack and magnus carlsen just
counter-attacked and he would lose that
would just be awful okay so he has put
his king's horn two squares forward so
this is already a signal that things are
gonna perhaps get a little bit
aggressive the game started
there he is oh
there he is
he pushes a pawn forward this is one it
might okay it's not heading towards your
favorite opening kayak
it's not heading towards the sicilian
night off but it is a sicilian
um
will this perhaps get more complicated
i think napoli actually will want to
keep more tension on the board but maybe
this is also a difference between the
player's homework magnus clearly spent
this morning studying that opening that
we saw in the last game and that really
helped him i mean he pretty much guided
him to victory in that last game napoli
actually it looks like he's well he's
taking a couple of pauses
he's playing slightly quicker now maybe
he's just trying trying to freestyle
just trying to get magnus into a
position he hasn't studied before um
different strategy there
we see that black
after a couple of trades of pawns in the
center of the board white's knight in
the center there black has now castled
which means moving your king across two
squares switching it with a rook this is
something to do
to keep your king safe in every game
very safe sensible play by magnus
they're probably actually retreating a
bishop there just dropping a bishop back
the moves are coming thick and fast
yeah this this actually has never been
played by magnus carlsen himself before
so definitely new territory for him even
world champions do that they use other
people too exactly and it's a lot more
fun to be honest to play a chess with
your friends a bit of banter comes and
he looks at it and says i like that or i
don't like that trying to push himself
to new levels that's the that's what
sets him apart his game always evolving
and actually if we bring up the board
here we see that magnus he's
okay he's just played a porn move but
he is trying to take his opponent's
bishop black's knight there on the
left-hand side he is trying to capture a
bishop with that knight normally this is
another thing we tell people not to do
especially when they're first starting
out the game don't put your knights on
the edge of the board but there has to
be a reason if you do and black's knight
will soon capture a bishop for someone
to be a second
and he needed someone who didn't respect
him too much respect between these two
guys
and we have a tweet that agrees with you
david from carl portman who says world
champions never ever coast fisher
kasparov carlson all pushed themselves
to their limits to stay ahead of the
opposition i think it's the position is
roughly level still chances for both
sides um if we bring up the board just
to show the last couple of moves not too
much has happened we saw that uh white
just advanced his queen slightly one
square it's really nice having the queen
of bishop on the same line teaming up
together maybe something could happen on
this diagonal later white might advance
his bishop towards black's king in the
meantime like pushes his bishop along
one square this is the dream diagonal
for every bishop you want to be on as
long a diagonal as possible horns are
going to try and block out this black
bishop over here on the left so very
sensible stuff from both sides early
days and magnus carlsen's last move
bringing rook into the game early days
ivanka likes black i like white let's
see who's going to be
correct
and the white bishop has moved all the
way to the right hand side of the board
and is right in the enemy camp and the
reason they played this is to exchange
off that very important dark squared
bishop that is surrounding the black
king uh two squares on the first go he
always said pawn to e4 that was the best
by test and
it just happened that that bishop
coordinates really well with the pawn
okay
here
exciting stuff there david
he's getting inside yes i am because
magnus has in fact traded off those
bishops and now it's a queen that we see
suspiciously close to the black king i
always get slightly concerned
when there's a queen hovering around a
king it's very brave though allowing a
queen so near your king
normally i don't recommend this for
people watching at home but magnus
carlsen he'll think that he has enough
defenders he has this position under
control
and then we see white's knight has
retreated so unable to link up with that
queen to attack right now yeah he's
breaking a little bit of the raw book
here uh magnus is so yeah we do have a
but we don't memorize this that's good
to hear this is all information that we
have to hand so that if we're preparing
for someone you can just pull up that
database and you go that is what i'm
going to play and then you reinforce
your short term memory it's a bit like
an exam i have a 12 year old student she
always says okay i need to revise my
notes just before your big game just
before your exam you just go over on the
computer you just play through things
repeat it and that's the best way the
best way to learn all right well they're
playing a lot of moves now what's
happening that's right so if we bring up
the board just to show what's happened
over the last few turns we left it after
black had advanced the pawn on this
left-hand side he is trying to advance
even further to attack this white knight
therefore
an opponent he said okay i'm going to
stop you advancing that pawn he just
pushed his pawn covering this important
square
therefore magnus castle said okay this
bishop i might as well take it off the
board it's no longer looking at my king
now across this diagonal that bishop was
traded for a night that's roughly a fair
trade knight's worth three points
bishop's worth three points but then we
see blacks opening the center magnus
carson trying to open things up those
pawns are doubled they are potentially
weak they also it's as if it's just one
pawn they don't i mean having two isn't
that much better than having one so
white long term is essentially down a
pawn um we see magnus carson meanwhile
just developing his queen bringing his
queen to a slightly more active square
advantage against that opening this is
an uh sicilian defense and we see oh and
the bar shifts
quite
a little bit for magnus there with that
move that's right so um napoli actually
he puts his knight in the center of the
board i think that that's generally it's
quite a logical move knights are
fantastic in the center of the board
your bank has a name for those nights
octonauts
in the last game
my octo knight got into trouble
all right well octo and i need to also
pay attention exactly
coverage with a british accent and uh
magnus has taken the warning that david
gave him and has pushed his pawn one
square up the board in order to stop
that knight getting to that very very
dangerous square and uh i expect we're
going to see
one of those rooks get into the game and
you've called it david the rook has
moved from the right hand side of the
board and it is now challenging the
black rook bit too comfortable for
magnus so far especially after winning
that last game magnus
okay magnus retreating his knight there
he's going to try and attack white's
queen soon
black's king is the only issue in his
position white's queen very near the
black king so if he can evict that queen
if he can kick the white queen away then
black will be very very happy i don't
think anybody's ever battled back from
two games down against magnus carlsen um
there we see a pair of rooks being
traded white has captured an enemy rook
that rook is immediately snapped off the
board as well actually napoleon's trying
to trade off all the rooks and we see
the bar slightly edging towards
carlson's direction that's because black
has the long-term advantages black is
the one who is uh well he should be
slightly happier with the trades it's
better than being knocked out yeah a
loss would just be dreadful and you can
see that magnus has taken off that night
with the bishop
and uh i'm expecting
some big trades coming in but i'm very
worried i'm very worried because black's
queen is just so beautiful
that's right white the more pieces come
off as well the more kind of useless
white's queen looks white's queen tried
to get at the black king but it just
doesn't have any backup um it doesn't
have any support trying to attack there
so
um nice trade by magnus carson a bishop
for a night in the center piece is so
beautiful i always imagine his engine is
a little bit like a red riding hood like
with a basket i will have a better night
i will have a better queen
[Applause]
and you know those little advantages
they actually collectively some i mean
they collectively build up to something
actually winning that's right and we
have seen the last pair of rooks leave
the board so now each side just has a
queen each side just has a knight
we've mentioned before the knight and
the queen they they team up so well
together um the knight is the only piece
which can move in ways that the queen
can't um white meanwhile is trying to
sneak into the black position with his
queen black just advances his king
that's a bit risky normally we don't
want to advance our king when the
opponent has a queen on the board but
magnus he knows that knights are a
king's best friend his knight black's
knight next to his king right now is a
great defender but it's very slightly in
black's favor that means yes with best
play with perfect play the position
should be a draw but we've mentioned
black is the one with the long-term
advantages white is the one on the
defensive so
maybe he can hold but he'll have to be
very very accurate in napoleon i think
he's just trying to he's okay and magnus
is doing the same remember we're talking
about those beautiful squares for the
night both nights are going to go into
their most perfect squares and there
will be octo knights supported by pawns
well someone should uh someone should
just print out this board and and give
to your banker so you can put on the
wall this beautiful beautiful chess game
but it's not just me that's admiring
magnus carlsen's technique definitely um
and they are making moves i mean we are
in the era of maybe the greatest chess
player
ever
and we know the maybe the greatest
football player ever died a few days ago
so
we are lucky to be alive in this era and
uh
wow what is happening on the board i see
the bar shifting obviously on the
opponent's side that's right a bit of a
strange move there by magnus carson he
just advanced his night two moves ago
but now he has retreated again so he's
actually lost a bit of time he's trying
to trade off white's knight here in the
center of the board black wants to
exchange pieces we mentioned long term
black is doing great so black wants to
trade off pieces but maybe white has an
opportunity here maybe white can say i'm
not going to let you trade knights but i
will let you trade queens and napoli
actually he's frowning maybe he's seen
this move he could
zoom his queen all the way at the board
and he's done it and he's done it and
the queen's going to get traded queens
have been traded now we see white is the
one attacking this pawn cannot be
defended white is about to win a pawn on
the left side of the wood i think magnus
carson he just forgot that this pawn
would would disappear and he's trying to
fight back has he blundered yes terribly
yes
just as we were saying how he he's great
at keeping control he's lost control
completely and we see black he was going
for this central pawn he saw this pawn
was not defended i mentioned it earlier
but if black takes it now his whole left
hand side will disappear suddenly white
will have three against none those pawns
will i mean it's going to be a pawn race
those pawns will run down the board is
magnus now losing this game
it's a race kaya it's a complete race
because magnus is a pawn down but you
can see he's using that extra pawn that
he has in the center and he's trying to
get them motoring and it all will turn
on whether
the noppomniachi can mobilize the pawns
on the left-hand side of the board if
they can get going well then i think it
will be game over for magnus that's
right if we imagine the board splits
into halves
on the right side magnus has a four
versus three advantage but that's very
difficult it's very difficult to create
one big important pawn um napoli
actually he has a three versus one
advantage on the left side and that's
why now we will see those pawns starting
to advance there we go white has
advanced to pawn on the left side right
at the corner there white is going to
try and make use of that three versus
one advantage it's a bit like sport now
it's a bit like football
white is outmatched he's out
he's outnumbering black on that left
side
it's looking difficult for magnus he
just has to hold that right uh that left
side and hope that his counter play his
that he can distract his opponent on the
on the right side of the board it's
difficult it's going to be a race as
your vancouver mentioned it's going to
be it's going to come down to one move
two moves and the pontiac's time is
ticking
definitely is he's turned the position
around he needs to make sure that he's
quick enough now though they have to
navigate with so little time in the
clock only two minutes and 20 seconds
for yana pognacci now the clock is
ticking but he is in a winning position
can he find the right moves with so
little time on the clock although
white's position is winning he does have
an extra pawn right now the problem is
if all of the pawns disappear even if
black's knight disappears if it ends up
with white just having a king and just
having a knight that's not enough
material to give checkmate at the end of
the game so he needs to make sure that
either he gets a pawn to the end of the
board and makes a new queen
or
he wins uh the black knight before that
but keeping pawns on the board he needs
to keep pawns in there we see magnus
carson trading off a set of pawns magnus
edging closer to the draw very slightly
um white giving a check now with his
knight king had to move quickly and
playing good moves so okay napoleon
moving his knight the race is on and i
will also mention before we take that
move that uh wesley saw and carnacuma
have started playing their second game
the first ended in a draw they are
playing their second we will go to that
later what's happening here david it's
well it's crazy isn't it the white king
has come forward to help the knight win
that poor back black horn in the center
and magnus has gone on the counter
attack he wants to win one of white's
pawns on the left-hand side of the board
that's right and one one of black's
pawns has disappeared here um that pawn
in the center has disappeared magnus
carlsen he needs to just try and get rid
of all of white's remaining pawns white
has four pawns left black needs to
sacrifice his knight for some of those
pawns he needs to trade off as many as
possible if he can get rid of all of
those pawns even at the cost of his
night it will be a draw but it's not
easy white still has just enough pawns
left to try and win this one we see the
bar as well there the computer thinks
4.6 advantage that is a winning
advantage for white but the margin for
error is so small one mistake and that
could drop back down to zero for those
pawns that is it is going to be a draw
that's right and we see black has
captured one of uh white's pawns on the
left there um
i think white is going to capture a pawn
as well black's last remaining pawn is
about to disappear from the board very
shortly it's going to be a case of can
black
not sure about that last move um oh the
computer hates it yeah that's the that's
the thing the one move is the difference
um between winning and losing the
problem for white now is that black is
going to trade his knight he's going to
sacrifice his knight for white's
remaining porn on the right there the
bottom pawn oh look at yana pognachi he
realizes he blundered a winning position
here
oh no
it just isn't his day it wasn't his day
he could have just taken that pawn last
move but he waited one move he was just
too slow he didn't want to calculate
what would happen if he captured that
pawn and so instead okay it is as you
called it david the knight has
sacrificed itself and now that king is
going to make a b line for the remaining
white pawn
okay and they've agreed to draw these
have agreed to draw blacks king
unfortunately unfortunately for napoli
actually black king is just going to
come up and gobble that pawn now on the
left side once that pawn disappears
white only has a night left that's not
enough material left to check mate